we've just been hearing from nicolas
sturgeon saying that this isn't a
grown-up conversation should we have one
about what is happening with public
health in
this part of the northwest in scotland
and why we've got this position of a
almost of accusations flying across the
border know
a conversation would be nice if the
scottish government had picked up the
phone because it's they've
changed the policy and you know that has
impacted on
on people here so i think nicholas
students say i should pick up the phone
well i'm
more than happy to but shouldn't they
have picked up the phone before they
before they they did this i i want to
hear from her how this
can be fair so today for instance bolton
has a significantly lower case rate than
dundee
bolton is under this travel ban dundee
is not
so i think we need an explanation from
the scottish government what are the
criteria that are being used here to
introduce these
decisions you know and is there going to
be any support
for individuals affected i've had emails
over the weekend
from uh residents of greater monster who
are thousands of pounds out of pocket as
a result of these changes
the scottish government has said this is
a sensible and proactive decision
to ensure that those variants are
suppressed as much as possible
and they can see the data here in north
the northwest of england
and those particular hotspots are the
ones that they've identified
you just don't accept it but we'll make
it consistent then
you know if there's a clear consistent
policy it should apply equally to any
cities in this position so
if bolton is under a travel ban with
cases under
300 then certainly dundee should be in
one with cases over
300 i'm not against taking action to
protect people's
health i just want to be assured that
it's fair
i'm being consistently applied across
across all areas and i have to say make
sure it's proportionate
so a couple you've emailed me have both
double jabbed
and they were going to book you know a
holiday in the scottish countryside
is that proportionate to say that they
can't they can't go
i personally don't think it is i don't
think the policy has been properly
thought through and i think the
government in scotland owes it to people
here to tell us
what are the criteria you know why a ban
still in place when cases are lower in
bolton
and how long will the ban be in place
here on city centre manchester and
salford you know
the first minister takes the stage on on
friday with no warning to anybody and
announces that
you know the uk's second city is going
under a travel ban
well that has an impact you know people
hear that statement being made it has an
impact
beyond just scottish visitors coming
people around the world will think
what's happening in manchester it's it's
it's very discourteous
not to me to the people of greater
manchester for this to be done
in this way in quite a high-handed way
without any explanation or or any
as i said any compensation for the loss
that people are suffering
i think i know the answer to this
question but is this about your
posturing and political ambition
i i just think she's insulting people
here who are emailing me
because i'm speaking up for them you
know to kind of make it all as though
that you know
it's all about politics you know and
none of this is real well i'll send
the first minister the the emails that
i've had and you know then maybe she
will see that it's
that it's real and you know the smp are
always the first aren't they
always the first to say oh the
westminster government has just done
something to us it didn't speak to us
and it's not fair
well we're a devolved administration too
here in greater manchester
i was elected by an electorate that
covers 2.8 million
people we have a measure of devolution
from from westminster
you know you would expect there to be
an understanding of that from the
scottish government but it just feels to
me
and particularly with this response it's
all about politics they're treating the
north of england with the same contempt
that the uk government
treats the north of england i speak out
about that when it's the the uk
government doing it but
i'm not going to not speak out about it
when it's the scottish government that
does the same
i mentioned to our viewers that you were
launching an environmental initiative
today a clean air zone for greater
manchester just
outline the bullet points of what you're
trying to achieve well from
may 30th next year all 10 boroughs of
greater manchester will become part of
the
the country's largest clean air zone but
unlike the scheme in birmingham
it will not include private cars
and it is not a congestion charge
because once people have got a clean
vehicle
there is there is no there is no charge
what we've done though is we've worked
with the government and thank you to
them for helping us with more financial
support
we can now offer people more time to
change more money
to change their their vehicle and we
think we can do this without a single
job or business
being lost but you know coming out of
the pandemic we've got to get more
serious about health
we can't tolerate things that we
tolerated before such as road pollution
that is harmful to the health
of the residents of greater manchester
it is time now to embrace
change but as we bring in a clean air
zone we're going to use it as a catalyst
to change public transport in greater
manchester putting our buses under
public control
integrating them with trams a new bike
hire scheme with e-bikes coming in today
all of it integrated
into one system called the b network
it's an exciting vision for our city
region